you're standing up right now career high
in minutes career high in points you
slide into the starting lineup for
Brunson and you absolutely delivered how
would you describe your performance God
is good he gives all the glory my
teammates did a great job give me a
place where I can be successful I'm
really proud of my team double overtime
against a really good team so you can't
that's enough for nothing better on a
Sunday you guys were down 14 and you
were able to fight your way back double
overtime finish your ninth win
consecutively what did you learn about
your team tonight man we got some goals
we got some dogs
um can't wait to get back celebrate but
you know we're not satisfied at all we
want to continue to get better uh
continue to make a push down the stretch
so that was magnificent thanks for the
show
shout out to Emmanuel quickley's mom no
jail in Brunson tonight quickly plays a
career high 55 minutes scores a career
high 38 points the Knicks win it in
double overtime 131 129 for our producer
Laurie privatera our director Jeff
Nelson